we begin with a fox news alert the white
house forced to walk back these
explosive comments made by president
biden a few hours ago when he seemed to
call for a regime change in russia
bent on rebuilding an empire will never
erase the people's love for liberty
we will have a different future a
brighter future rooted in democracy and
principle hope and light
of decency and dignity of freedom and
possibilities
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power
the white house quickly followed up with
a statement telling fox news quote he
was not discussing putin's power in
russia or a regime change end quote
biden also saying in his speech that
putin isn't winning
that this war has already been a
strategic failure for russia already
having lost children myself i know
that's no solace to the people
of lost family
but he putin
thought ukrainians would roll over and
not fight
rather than breaking ukrainian resolve
russia's brutal tactics have
strengthened the resolve
rather than driving nato apart the west
is now stronger and more united than it
has ever been
katie i want to go ahead and start with
you a lot to dig into right there
president biden giving so many mixed
messages um and also essentially saying
that you know russia is not winning the
war we do know the ukrainians have been
very strong and they have put up a very
good fight but there are so many people
who say this president this president
who said that he would use diplomacy to
ensure that this wouldn't happen
um is now talking about removing a
dictator and a war that reaches on your
thoughts about how he's handling this
and also how it resonates with voters
well the president has repeatedly said
that he has no interest in getting the
united states into world war iii but
given his stumbling statements and
sloppy communication throughout this
process he may just get us into world
war iii as a result of a
miscommunication which can lead to a
miscalculation which is how most wars
start you have the president this week
claiming that sanctions are not about
deterrence when the entirety of his
other
his administration whether it's the
secretary of state the white house press
secretary or his national security
adviser have been saying for weeks that
sanctions are meant to deter and then of
course this week he was in poland
speaking to u.s troops and then after
adamantly claiming that u.s troops would
no longer would never be going into
ukraine it's not a nato country but that
every inch of nato territory would be
defended the president spoke
nonchalantly like u.s troops were going
to be going into ukraine now this was
supposed to be a foreign policy speech
to define president biden's first term
the rest of it got lost as a result of
the statement that he made at the end
about vladimir putin needing to go and
the white house statement following up
is not what was heard around the world
but was heard around the world is that
the biden administration is changing
strategy here and not only are they just
going you know supporting ukrainians
they are now interested in removing
vladimir putin of course that brings up
a whole other set of questions about
okay well who's going to replace him
what does that process look like
who's going to manage that process so
it's you know you have to be so careful
about the things you say and the
president has not been doing that there
is so much to parse through here but i
want to stick on that point that you uh
talked about which is this idea that
there could be troops on the ground that
biden himself suggested it i want
everyone to listen to this soundbite
see when you're there and sometimes
you've been there you're going to see
you're going to see women
young people standing standing in the
middle of the front of a damn tank
just saying i'm not leaving
i'm holding my ground
news a statement on this saying quote
the president has been clear we are not
sending u.s troops to ukraine and there
is no change in that position so more
mixed messaging here joey your thoughts
on what would happen if troops are on
the ground and we are engaged in a world
war iii
this is really serious
if we've learned anything this week is
that we cannot trust the president
united states to tell us the truth or
even know what he wants to say and we
certainly can't trust his white house
this week alone we've had the president
refute every single person in his
cabinet who's spoken on this issue from
the press secretary to the secretary of
state about what deterrents are and what
sanctions are meant to be and now in in
two days we get troops are or not going
to go into ukraine we are or not going
to use chemical weapons in kind it's a
very specific thing to say and now we
are or not going to support the regime
change of putin and russia listen this
is scary times and this is not the
person this is not the way you want the
person in charge to be talking about
these things in the fact that they think
and that large portions of the media
will allow them to just sweep these as
gas these are not gas these are
important and incoherent things that the
president's saying and i'll tell you
what man i just would hate to be in
camouflage utility setting in front of
him with him looking me in the face
saying when you get to ukraine and then
have someone from the white house say oh
the president's been clear on this what
is clear about any of this hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else